good morning everyone my name is eric
serra twitchin devil talking about I'm
talking about radiative transfer theorem
and its application are four levels of
directional reflectance distribution
function from surface reflected radiance
so I'd like to start from basic
equations and definitions be directional
reflectance distribution function is
defined as a ratio of surface reflected
radiance and down villain radiance
surface level provided that all dongle
flux comes from single direction brdf is
required to set up boundary conditions
for native transfer model which is used
in rizal retrievals cloud retrievals
computations of radiative budget so
radiance of light can present the sum of
director and scattered part and diffuse
part and diffused part is governed with
a creative transfer equation which is in
one dimensional case has form of
equation one and 1d case I mean that
nothing depends on a horizontal position
all properties of all functions are
depend on their own vertical position
since this is a integral differential
equation it has to be supplemented with
boundary conditions and they will
consider three different boundary value
problems first problem is schematically
depicted in the Left figure most fear is
eliminated from its top and at the
bottom we have reflected a surface which
is described with brdf Rome in this case
boundary conditions
given these equations to the second
problem is similar but there is no
reflection at the bottom in this case
boundary conditions arguing with
equations 3 and the last problem is same
atmosphere but flipped or atmospheric
layers are just taken in him in inverse
order in this case boundary conditions
has form of equations for I will denote
the solutions of these three problems
with letters l I and J and some time ago
I found a relationship between these
three solutions and the idea fro it is
given with the equation 5 i'm sorry it
is hardly readable especially taking
into account that the last term on the
right is quadruple integral but it can
be simplified in the form of 6 so this
is an integral equation fredholm
integral equation of the second kind
where the source function s and Colonel
arguing with expressions sell so usually
what people medal is radiance L at
optical earth thickness of tau team we
can't measure a surface erdf which is
property of surface itself with only can
measure reflect radiance and the problem
is how to derive brdf again as a
property of the surface from the
measurement of reflected radiance
equation 5 can be inverted well
basically rewritten in the form of eight
where the source and kernel of that
equation are given with
regions 9 the problem is that likely
this equation is you post problem
because the exponential factors in both
s and K can get really huge and we'll
see that this causes a problem with
solving equation 8 but if we look at
these two equations six and eight we can
see that they have similar form so it
makes sense to consider an equation of
that form and try to solve it and at
least developed method of solving it so
let's say consider equation 10 there are
several approaches to solve numerically
say textbooks offer a successive
approximation approach which says take
source functional initial guess and then
substitute into the equation and the
traded as many times as necessary
however this method may not converge in
quite simple case I just throat one of
them it's fine but it's true the
equation cannot be solved can also be
sold with a quadrature method but if we
discretize the equation for the function
of two variables we can end up with a
linear system system of linear algebraic
equation of great dimension and so we
need to develop a few effective methods
of solving it so the script ization i
use is based on a gaussian quadrature
two polar a variable new and irregular
grid with respect to azimuth angle Phi
so when I apply this discretization end
up with the system 12 where source
vector which is actually matrix f ji and
matrix of the system itself ki are given
with expressions 13 it seems that a
direct solution of this system well may
take a lot of time because of the
dimension of the system so from my point
of view iterative methods can be a more
efficient in this case the next slide
summarizes stationary stationery
iterative approaches for linear systems
Richardson trations is basically
discretized version of successive
approximations for integral equations
and this method is the least efficient
[Music]
theoretically Gao ze alliterations is
the most efficient method but sometimes
in order to get control about get
control on how far the next rate jumps
from the current iterate it may be
useful to use relaxation so successful
for relaxation method just blends
current and next iterations obtained
with Gaussian so I will consider this
method in the case of two-dimensional
system of linear equations and here is
mathematic in plement ation of that
well call this trivial probably but
basically i use mathematica you know to
verify my Fortran codes so I don't
basically use fancy features mathematica
provides I need just simple instrument
that can get a result quickly let me go
back a little bit to initialize the
system to show how it works oops yeah
okay so i will need some other routines
0 the routines to perform actual
computations here
they are basically integration routines
quadrature computations and file reading
and drinking so you go the first case
pristine atmosphere know our soul
surface bottom surface is described with
a BF x disk given by nielsen coast
equation 18 in the atmosphere we have
all the Rayleigh scattering so a
scheduler phase function is fairly
simple optical thickness of the
atmosphere I chose of point one which
roughly is about green light 550
nanometers so discretization scheme is
described here the code presents a just
general setup for calculation here i
compute colonel and then Colonel matrix
and here is the iterative process itself
you see the very beginning it does not
converge but beginning from with
duration number eight and nine it start
it starts to converge for everything and
finally the process converges using
probability 12 to 23 24 traditions in
this computation I choose a relaxation
parameter of point 9 given in magenta
empirically I found that this really
provides the
fastest convergence unfortunately this
method may not converge at all for more
complex problems I will talk about that
later but now I just want to show how
accurate the solution is on the right is
the solution I just obtained in the
middle result of radius transfer
modeling with code disord and relative
difference sorry in the middle desert
model and on the right relative
difference between them we can see that
relative difference is small for almost
all solar Zeta angles except this one
the very low Sun in this case we CL 2
difference huge well you can say two
solutions are all the same order of
magnitude but not it's it's actually bad
but in a remote sensing community nobody
cares about so long solo son so that's
that's okay from the perspective of
remote sensing community that's
completely okay accuracy is great now
let's consider a little bit more
complicated problem I add some era solo
to the same atmosphere so I considered
transported mineral dust our sole model
with optical thickness of point one so
total optical thickness of that Monsieur
is a point to now and I used the same
brdf model but slightly less reflective
parameter a which defines how bright the
surfaces is point2 now instead of point
49 and I will not perform any
computations here now I just was want to
show that exponential factor I
talked about is really really huge and
unfortunately iterative process does not
converge with any relaxation parameter I
tried many of themselves however it
makes sense to solve their problem
rather inverse problems so soft food
reflected radiance rod and rather than
brdf and this slide presents the code
setting up computations and these slides
present computations for three different
relaxation parameters I begin with
parameter point nine and we can see that
iterations converge quickly so for any
for any solar Jane angle no problem
anywhere really but what if we do not
want any relaxation so if relaxation
parameter is up one so just go see
attractions we can see that the same
iterations converge even faster we need
only four instead of seven before well
we can expect that if we increase the
oxygen parameter even more we can get in
faster convergence but unfortunate
that's true with 1.1 we have again seven
trations so it seems that food direct
problem we do not need relaxations at
all so here is the comparison between
the result I just obtained with the sort
modeling and relative difference between
them
so the difference is fairly small but
starting from a certain source an angle
we can see a noisy behavior of the
desert modern brief explanation of that
is that it is obtained with summation of
cosine free series and it is done with a
single precision because of the design
of that code so probably the method i
developed can get better better quality
of the solution now it is important to
see the contributions of different terms
of the equation I consider it to the
total solution so I consider the direct
light contribution given by equation 20
and my initial guess given by the sum of
first to our terms on the right hand
side and the total solution so the
comparison is shown in this animation so
a direct light contribution on the right
initial guess in the middle and the
total solution on the right so direct
light contribution is a significantly
smaller than total solution but initial
guess provides almost full solution
already so this gives a hint how to
solve inverse problem using the direct
problem solution all we need to do is to
assume that brdf can be presented as a
sum of linear combination for known
functions and the problem reduces to the
search for the coefficients of this
linear form in this case source function
and kernel function presented as
sums of known functions again and the
iterative approach for this problem is
to stage at any iterative step we have
to perform two operations first we need
to find a minimal square feet of
reflected radiance as the initial guess
we use only source functions and then we
find coefficients alpha naught and use
them to compute approximate reflected
radiance at all directions necessary to
evaluate integral that defines model
functions of the next step the next step
we feed model functions different model
functions from the first step and find
the coefficients of the linear form for
that step then use them again to compute
the next approximation of reflected
radiance and so on and so on so we need
to solve one more problem model
functions are not known in their
functional form they are given in table
has tables at certain certain values of
their arguments so custom function
linear feet solve the problem of this
fitting it's nearly trivial and again I
will consider the keys I used with
direct problem kernel functions for brdf
up just the same function used an actual
bear gear but I don't I assume that
I don't know the key efficient so this
code basically sets up everything chose
a random directions and thus pretend to
pretend to simulate actual measurements
so these random directions are then used
to retrieve values of if ket R aliens
from my modeling results I used before
and this code here is just
implementation of the iteration process
I just described so here how it works
surprising thing is that we do not need
actually many trations because after
iteration number one we don't see any
change with six digits they are all the
same each iteration unfortunately takes
quite a long time as well at least with
Mathematica implementation but the
matter of fact is that we need only one
of them we don't need to perform 53 over
there just one of them is enough so this
slide shows another example I choose
randomly again certain directions 15
directions positive part of x axis shows
sergeant angles and scattered dots show
random directions of observations and in
this case it is the comparison of the
my solution and theoretical values used
to obtain see reflected radiance with
relative transfer modeling we can see
that in the worst case of coefficient
alpha alpha for relative error is about
1.5% I'm really not surprised to see
that because we saw that the difference
between the source solution for a
reflected radiance and my solution can
be about 2% easily and the third
solution I use as a model measurement is
quite noisy so i can see that this
result is well the success he ah so here
is my conclusions a method to solve a
fredholm integral equation of the second
kind of two variables was proposed the
method was used to solve the equation
relation surface reflected radiance and
their GF solon for brdf is a new post
problem and iterations may not converge
while a problem for direct problem for
surface radiance is well posed and
iterations converge very quickly so this
gives an idea how to develop iterative
procedure to get bear DF is union that
it is presented the sum of known
functions and this iterative process can
go just really quickly that's all thank
you